[Music]
you all started because we interested in
what kind of functions uh G bacteria can
do and you turn out we found this one
functions that were important for the
human physiology is the reduction of B
rubben to youron youron was then
converted to your B which causes the
urine color to be
yellow one of the project all have been
working on is to identify this enzyme
that that is a mystery enzyme have now
been characterized before and this
enzyme is responsible for converting be
Ruben to your blendin and that's
performed by the G
bacteria the importance of this enzyme
Billy Ruben reductase is that it helps
our body break down heem and convert it
into products that we can get rid of as
just part of our normal healthy course
of life but in order to understand what
microbes are doing that the first step
that we needed to to do was actually
find the mystery Gene that performs this
function we had a really collaborative
effort with the hall lab to
identify First a group of bacteria that
could reduce Billy Rubin in the lab and
then our side we were able to look at
the genomes of those bacteria and
eventually identify likely enzymes that
we were then able to confirm their
functions and then look at bigger
picture trends like the relationship of
that Gene to different uh different
kinds of diseases very commonly in
infants uh we'll see a buildup of excess
Billy Ruben which then can uh cause the
coloring of the skin and eyes uh cause a
little bit of pain for them and fevers
and in more severe cases lead to uh you
know brain damage and you know hearing
loss and more severe effects once we had
an idea of what enzyme was in involved
in this we were then able to go into uh
these large publicly available data sets
from Young infants healthy adults and
patients with IBD and so we were able to
kind of for the first time show that
these young infants in the first you
know 30 to 60 days of Life are often
missing this Gene while healthy adults
almost always have it we were also able
to see that about 30% of IBD patients
were also missing that Gene now that we
have uh a much better understanding of
what bacteria are involved this can
hopefully lead to some better outcomes
in terms of the infants that develop
jaundice B Ruben react is just T of
Iceberg of the uh Manu functions or got
bacteria perform and we want to further
characterize more enzymes like it to
understand the role of the G micob
perform in our human
hands